we got news that um actually i don't
know if we have this article picked up
uh pulled up but we should talk about it
we've got news right now
ten senators
uh republicans have agreed with
democrats on gun control
and so i remember you know luke was
telling me this he was like yeah ten
this is the other day he's like ten
republican senators are cutting a deal
with uh democrats for gun control and i
was like no that can't be right
that that puts them over the filibuster
they're going to get that passed turns
out it's true
so
why is it
that you never have the inversion of
that story where the 10 democrats to
side with republicans on gun access
never happens
and so what you see is the narrative is
always skewing in the direction of the
democratic establishment and what
progressives want or just eliminating
people's rights to right right right
because the media is manipulating people
and it's controlled by forces outside
the united states well well so the point
i was trying to get to with bill you
mentioned algorithms is that the first
iteration of narrative control is
mainstream media new york times they're
losing that what's happening now is big
tech is just
well all they got to do is this
if you've got 50 conservatives and 50
democrats ban one conservative and now
it's a lopsided match
you got let's say it's five on five
basketball you ban one conservative and
it's 5v4 who's likely going to win oh
without a doubt the five people and
that's basically what's happening i
think there were with social media
you're 100 right like watching the way
conservatives get banned i don't know if
there was shadow banning back in the day
when i was like super progressive and
woke but i was straight threatening to
fight senators every day and just like
getting followers getting verified and
now my like tiny instagram is shadow
band and i don't even post conservative
stuff but i have famous followers who
are like anti-vaxx or you know whatever
and i'm certainly shadow band on me but
you're also you're anti-authoritarian i
would assume yes yeah so oh no i'm here
to pitch my pro authoritarian platform
and promote my comedy dates at the house
of comedy next week in public but like
meaning that they punish right and left
right that are anti-authoritarian but
the only thing i was going to say with
you uh the only thing i kind of disagree
with with what you said about the is i
mean i remember back back in the day uh
the amount of bills that were mostly
like
anti-corporation you know whatever that
the democrats would
some of them would pass but all the
centrist like max baucus types would uh
c block it and republicans will come
over whatever i think the reason in this
case with guns
is the democrats don't have much
backbone right like they're wishy-washy
on everything they sell out everything
but i feel like guns and abortion
are like their two
things where there's not gonna be
compromise on that or else it's like
just go be a republican but but i do
mean a more modern history
like under the biden administration i
agree with you yeah with with uh with
trump the trump it was the populist
insurgency in 2016. but uh bernie loses
trump wins
bernie failed at storming the gates of
the democratic party trump succeeded at
storming against republicans so now you
get people like bill crystal you get
these neocons the lincoln project types
who are effectively democrats right but
it's because which i am not happy about
the uniparty coalesced around what the
democrats are since then what have we
seen in 20 so we get a donald trump
presidency in beginning of 2017 you've
got republicans controlling congress
they do nothing in fact they agreed with
the russiagate investigations and move
forward saying well we've got to be
reasonable so crazy so since then liz
cheney our progressive hero
so i i think it was michael miles who
brought this up where where is the
argument from the right about repealing
the nfa or guaranteeing gun access it's
always a compromise on giving away our
rights i think nfa people need some
education i thought the nfa was uh was a
an entity it's a national it's just an
act that you can repeal it's the bill
yeah it sounds too much like nsa people
think oh i'm not getting rid of an
entire department no the nfa has to stay
we need the national firearms department
you know atf yeah
they think nfa is atf but nfa is an act
that basically might
a lot of weapons now refresh me tell me
exactly what it is so you know how they
banned pot the first time
you needed a tax stamp
so and they were like well we can't ban
it let's make it so you need a tax stamp
to buy it and then we'll stop issuing
tax stamps the the national firearms act
was basically like certain weapons can
be classified requiring you to get
special forms and pay a special tax at
the time it was the equivalent of three
thousand dollars today it's 200 bucks
has never gone up but you got to get an
atf background check check an fbi
background check you gotta get
fingerprinted at your local police
station or sheriff's office it takes
upwards of six months maybe a year to be
able to get one of these items so they
didn't ban them that would violate the
constitution they just made it
prohibitively expensive and
time-consuming to get i keep thinking
like we're in unprecedented times with
this inflation with this technology with
uh the connectedness of the of the world
but at the same time i keep thinking of
1928 and like right before the
depression or are we in the midst of the
beginning of the great depression times
two and like nazi germany when they
started slowly taking away gun rights
then all of a sudden the reichstag
caught fire the parliamentary building
and hitler blamed the communists and
then just took everyone's rights away
and then stripped everybody with the
enable enabling act which a lot of
people compared to the patriot act yes
and people have even said that hitler
started that fire as a false flag and
then blamed the communists just to seize
power so we need to be this is like that
shooting in texas and i'm saying
specifically i'm not saying anything
that about that being a false flag or
anything i don't think it was but lydia
just perked up for people
tragedy as an excuse to seize our guns
is insane or our right to guns that's
what i'm talking about not the guns
themselves it's the right to own the gun
this is something that i've been talking
about since uh you know
2001 in new york city is that whenever
you give up your rights during
emergencies governments will make up
emergencies so they could take away your
rights
and i think that's an important
perspective to understand here because
we have allowed the government a lot
especially within the last two and a
half years and they have essentially
weaponized the intelligence agencies
they have weaponized the cdc the fda for
their own personal benefit they have
become more and more political and now
that same government that of course has
been locking you down arresting people
for not wearing a mask arresting people
for having a business open are telling
you that we need to protect you by
taking away your ability
real quick i want to add um i have i
have uh oh
i've woken people up i'll put it that
way i guess i could say red pill
um by telling people
red flag laws this is what they're
passing yo this is stop and frisk on
steroids you know stop and frisk jamie i
was against it yeah yeah yeah i'm
against it the the idea so
it's called the terry stop the idea is
that a cop can walk up to any person for
any reason that well not necessarily any
reason but probable cause which can
basically be any reason which is they
don't look like all of us was
essentially what they were doing so so
let me get into that because this is
it's crazy so
the idea is all this gun crime so you go
to a neighborhood you see someone you
think is suspicious you stop them you
frisk them you can't put your hands in
their pockets if you feel something you
can take it out if it feels like drugs
if it feels like a weapon and so all of
a sudden you get these reports that
young black and latino men are being
stopped by these cops all the time and
basically being harassed and people are
getting hurt people getting arrested
turns out bloomberg ordered them to go
after black and brown kids literally
like latino and black kids in these
neighborhoods and he said that's where
the crime's at and it's like okay so
here's what i tell these these activists
that are like yes red flag laws i said
stop and frisk take a look at this
report an nypd i think it was a
nypd guy
said people cops were being ordered
specifically to target black kids and
then bloomberg said yeah well that's
because it's their neighborhoods it's
like well there's one thing to say
neighborhood it's another thing to
actually tell to go after a race
so imagine what stop what red flag laws
are going to be in new york city when
they pass red flag laws
dude
these these the i i've told these people
i said i mark my words you are going to
hear a story about some family man who's
black the cops come to his house bang on
the door and say someone reported you
even if the dude doesn't even own a gun
just like stop and frisk they're going
to come in the house
bad things are eventually going to
happen
we should not allow the government
rights to violate fourth amendment
rights because the challenge with stop
and frisk i'm sorry with the red flag
laws is that people are ambushed it's
it's non-adversarial court
the government should if the government
wants to do something they have to file
you get a chance to respond it's due
process but we heard these stories about
the cops walking to someone's house and
being like you've been served a red
red flag order give me your guns
and the guy's like no and then so i
think we talked about last week
baltimore dude died because he was like
what do you mean you're coming to take
my guns i have no idea what's going on
oh it's your your sister she said that
you're a danger to yourself and others
so we're taking your weapons now
there's been there's been a number of
incidences like this with states that
have red flag laws that have implemented
them and have have hurt a lot of
innocent civilians implementing them and
just look at what we what we have to
deal with swatting with false reports of
people calling in bull crap to this
specific location imagine what's going
to happen with red flag laws imagine
what's going to happen with neighbors
who have disagreements with each other
partners girlfriends boyfriends that
argue with each other they're going to
abuse this system to call the police to
break down your door to take away your
ability to defend yourself i mean that's
that's a new level of insanity that that
we have to push back against these
talking points are literally something
that i've never
heard i feel like this string of
podcasts that i've been on have should
just be called the red pilling of jamie
hilstein
because i've never heard it
like what you were saying
first luke and what you were just saying
now about uh stop and frisk which i was
adamantly against or the patriot act
which i was adamantly against
those
again i would like to think i'm a pretty
intelligent dude and i saw
zero connection until now with the
school shooting being used to take away
gun rights as the war because i know i'm
anti-war so in the patriot act right
like the left you're anti-war so the
patriot act goes and i go well this is
i'm seeing that clearly because i go
well this is already something i'm
against and this is clearly taking away
our rights but because also with my side
it's like we're anti-gun a school
shooting happens and you go that is also
a tragedy that is a tragedy that
destroys me emotionally just like
september 11th destroyed people
emotionally
and then they try to take the guns at no
point would i have compared that
to the patriot act after september 11th
or after the war because i'm just like
but it doesn't line up but it is it's
the same thing
this is the
the issue i see with the left so often
is single layer issues
is that they'll say
we had a school we had this big major
tragedy kids lost their lives it's time
to enact these gun laws and i said
what's what what's the equation there
how did you go from kids lost their
lives to it's time to enact gun laws how
do those things connect in why in your
mind does one come after the other
because i'm not convinced enacting gun
laws will has anything to do with with
the tragedy at the school so that we
need background checks dude pass the
background check
what next we need to we need to raise
the the legal age okay all right well
there there's potentially something that
may have stopped him when i'm old enough
um
apparently uh uh i suppose the issue
there is legal adults have a right to
keep and bear arms now you're butting up
against you're trying to pass laws that
completely violate constitutional rights
of legal adults because one person
committed a crime so look
i don't believe
the when when there is a tragedy the end
result should be over uh overhaul of our
national system because of one incident
one human out of 300 million who
committed a crime it it doesn't follow
but most importantly the stop and frisk
thing right away with red flag laws if
the if the left that killed me because
you're right because it's gonna affect
communities of color it's gonna but this
is what i'm saying like
i'm gonna sit here and be like it's a
fact that bloomberg came out and was
like we we told the cops to go after
black kids right and then i'm like hey i
kind of think that's a really bad thing
what do you think is going to happen
when you now say go into their houses
right and for some reason crickets from
the left they're like no we want this
i'm like
well are you for or against these and
this is why people need to consume
different media that's not just their
own nietzsche because i i've never heard
someone compare it like that and i doubt
they're tuning in right now uh and one
of the forty thousand but i will real
quick just a shout out there are many
leftists who are pro-guns oh no no no no
no that i know but i'm saying the people
who right now are saying ban all the
guns ban all the guns mark's marx
was pro-gun okay listen under no pretext
should arms and ammunition be
surrendered any attempt to disarm the
workers must be frustrated by
by force if necessary i mean that's marx
that's mark not a big fan of the guy
come on
i made a tweet i said under no pretext
did the right to keep bear arms be
infringed because like i was like i want
to combine the two and i'm like get mad
at me liberals we got marx and jefferson
the conversation that's worth having is
the
is the power creep of weapons and armor
so at some point we've talked about like
technically constitutionally you have
the right to any kind of weapon uh even
a nuclear bomb but it's not necessarily
ethical to give every citizen a nuclear
bomb that they can drop on accident and
set off
so put up or shut up conservatives yeah
there are there i said it they got mad
at me for it know i'm not no so i i
basically said the rights given bear
arms will not be infringed whether you
like it or not the founding fathers
didn't realize that would include nukes
and biological weapons because those
those are arms armaments so i'm like
maybe we need to have an amendment in
the constitution and be like
okay we don't mean that like that
because like it's like you're saying the
power creep of these weapons yeah if
elon musk were to arm his satellites his
uh
star links with like rods from god like
tungsten rods and that's like no no elon
sorry well no no no no no that would be
dope though no no no hold on halliburton
lockheed martin boeing these companies
like you're saying the government gives
them this monopoly on for corporations
but but ian
you know information is the the battle
scene right now so information could be
more detrimental especially when it
comes to influencing culture than
nuclear weapons i think we have to
understand that's what's happening right
now with a few multinational
corporations that are tied in with the
government they are creating technology
and whether you call call it fourth
generational warfare or fifth
generational warfare we are seeing some
extremely negative consequences to that
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there